Est-ce qu'il peut retirer 20€?
Je sais pas, je sais pas...
Je sais pas, il faut que je regarde,
peut-être sur un livret A,
peut-être avec un taux 1%...
Fait pas le con, Mercier, répond!
Oui, oui il peut.
Tu sais ce qui te reste à faire.
Ça va, mec?
T'as pas cette impression, des fois,
que la vie,
elle est pas ce qu'elle semble... Être?
Mais, putain, c'est quoi?
Je sais pas, je sais pas!
Mais il faut qu'on mette une réponse!
Bah, beuh... Je sais pas, je-je cherche!
Vite, il faut que tu trouves un truc!
Met n'importe quoi, je sais pas!
Je met Gangnam Style?
Bah non! Non, surtout pas!
Je met quoi? Je met quoi, je sais pas, moi, j'ai pas de...
Je-je sais, mais... Invente! Tu sais quoi, Invente!
Ok, ok, ok.
"Arrête de nous faire chier, connasse"...
...T'es sérieux?
J'ai paniqué.
Monsieur le président!
Monsieur le président, on a besoin de votre aide sur ce coup là!
Ça fait:
Na na na na na na naa, na na na na...
*Distributeur: C'est Never Gonna Give You Up, de Rick Astley.*
Merci!